[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM BERLIN: Hi.
I'm Sam, and this is Maurice.
We're both leads
on the Sheets team.
I lead the creation
of the Sheets B4 API,
and Maurice led the Slides API.
And we're here to
talk to you today
about using Google Apps
Script and the G Suite editors
to make your life easier,
automate internal processes,
and really just make things
simpler and better for you.
So we're going to walk
through some demos today.
We're going to give an
appetizer demo and then
a longer run-through
of a process
that an HR person might
use to hire people.
And I'll let Maurice talk about
his demo when it comes to him.
And our goal today
is really to show you
how you can use App Script
and spend less money getting
the stuff you need to do done.
Companies spend billions
of dollars a year
automating their workflows.
And that's not even
mentioning the time
they spend figuring
out how to do it.
They have to contact
people to build it and work
through everything in
order to get it all done.
With Apps Script, we can
take a lot of the pain away.
These are some stories
of some customers
that have used Apps Script
to make their life better.
My most favorite one, by
far, is the very last one,
where a company simplified
a horrible revision merge
nightmare of taking all
these different files,
merging them together, and then
creating some kind of output.
And they simplified
their lives by using
G Suite to automate it,
generating a PDF at the end.
And what previously took
about 40 hours a month now
takes under three
and saves them,
they estimated, over
$100,000 a year.
And a customer literally said--
this is a natural quote--
finally I can take a vacation.
So our goal here
is for you to be
able to take a vacation
from automating
all of these workflows.
So here's a simple example.
Everyone likes parties, right?
So imagine that you're
throwing an office party,
and you want to send out RSVPs.
You want to analyze
who responds to it,
what parts of the
company they're from.
Are they from sales, are
they from engineering?
Book a venue based
on the results.
Do you have enough people
that can fit into one?
Do you need to split it
up into multiple venues?
What kinds of places do
people like to go to?
Traditionally, this would
be a lot of manual labor.
You'd have to pore
through all the results,
figure out how many
people there are,
where they belong
in the company,
maybe what office they're from,
where you can host things.
Or instead of doing that, you'd
purchase some turnkey solution,
which would cost a lot of money.
But realistically,
office parties
aren't all that important.
So you'd probably just
have some poor person
doing the most
minimal thing possible
and throwing a
rather generic party.
With App Scripts
and Docs editors,
things are pretty easy.
You can create a Google
Form, collect user names
when sending out the form,
get all your results back,
and associate the
form with the sheet.
In Forms itself, you can
analyze all the responses.
You can see 66% of people
said yes, they're in.
33% said, no, they're not.
And in Sheets, it'll sync
right back up into Sheets,
and you can look and
do analysis in Sheets
if you want to do it in
a slightly manual way,
maybe using Sheets Explore
or asking questions of it.
But you can also
create an Apps Script
associated with the sheet in
order to do things for you.
So here's a 20-line
example of how
you could create a very
straightforward app script that
looks at all of your data
in the sheet and figures out
who's in sales,
who's in engineering.
So I'll go through each line and
explain what's happening here.
So at the top, we
use the Groups app.
And we get the eng@mycompany.org
and the sales@mycompany.org
groups.
And then we get the
active spreadsheet,
because the script is
associated with the spreadsheet.
And we get the data
from that spreadsheet
up until the last row of data.
And we start the engineering
and sales counts at 0
and then loop through
all of our data.
And we say is this
user in engineering--
by asking is the engGroup-- does
this engGroup have this user's
email address.
If not, are they
in the salesGroup?
Does it have that
user's email address?
And we just increment the sales
and the engineering variables
by one.
And then at the very end, after
we've collected all of that,
we go back to the spreadsheet,
and we get the sheet name
with results.
And we get a range where
we want to put the data in.
We say this is how
many people were eng,
this is how many
people were in sales.
And so this is a very
straightforward example
of how you can use Apps Script
just analyzing your data
sheets automatically,
associating it with groups,
and putting your data
back in the sheet.
So all of this
code is JavaScript.
It's all stored in the
cloud with revision history.
So if you make a mistake, you
can go back in time and fix it.
And it's hosted and
run in the cloud, too.
So you don't have
to spin up any jobs,
have maintenance deal with
having all of your servers
running, seeing if anything
goes wrong with them.
And it's all secure, and
it comes with G Suite.
But automating parties
isn't what brought you here.
Businesses have a lot
more critical tasks,
like hiring people.
There are a lot of
steps to hiring someone.
You have to send offer letters.
You have to collect
employee information.
You have to have them sign NDAs
and verify their employment
history, and so on and so forth.
So I'm going to walk through a
demo of how you could automate
the process of hiring someone
if you can switch to the demo
machine.
So here's a spreadsheet.
And I filled it in with some
basic examples here of employee
name, salary, manager
name, the team, and whether
or not an offer letter was
sent, the offer letter URL,
if they signed an NDA,
and so on and so forth.
There's an extra column in
here for their email address,
which I've kept hidden.
Because I'm going to,
right now, actually
make this an interactive demo.
And if you'd like to, you can
see that there is a URL here--
goo.gl, capital
PDW, capital EQT.
And if you want, you can go
to this place and fill it out.
Just remember, it's
all being recorded,
and you can fill out a
fake name if you want to
onto the employee tracking bit.
So the idea here is that-- let's
say there is an HR manager.
And they have this
spreadsheet with their data
and a form for new hires.
And they want to send this
out to hiring managers
and say is there anyone
that you want to hire.
If so, fill out their
email address, their name,
their salary,
their manager name.
You can look what the form
looks like from the manager's
perspective.
And it's just here.
You see a little form where
they can type the stuff in
and submit the results.
Others-- let's go
to Google Forms.
And the form is synced
up with a spreadsheet.
So the results come
into the spreadsheet.
At this point, you can click
on this Workflows, which
is this custom menu item that
you added with Apps Script,
and click Send
New Offer Letters.
What that's going
to do is iterate
through the spreadsheet, similar
to how we did the party example
and create a
customized Google Doc
for the employee of
their offer letter,
and then email it to
them with the link
to their customized Google Doc.
Afterwards, it'll mail
that to the employee.
And the employee will basically
see, in their email, the link
to their doc and be
able to click on it.
And so I'll show you
what that looks like.
So here's one user.
It says you're hired.
Dear John Doe,
congratulations, you're hired.
Please view your offer letter,
which includes the next steps,
at this URL.
You open the URL, and you
see this customized Google
Doc for John Doe.
And it has their
salary, their name.
The title is specific
for John Doe.
And it says to
continue the process,
please fill out this NDA.
So we click on this link.
This NDA is hosted
by App Script.
App Script is acting as a
web app in this scenario.
And here's where it goes.
It says here's an NDA.
Click here to sign it.
When you sign it, it
comes back and says thanks
for signing the NDA.
And that was also
hosted by App Script.
And you can see that
the Apps Script then
filled in that yes, the
NDA was signed by John Doe.
And none of the others
yet had filled it out.
And if, for example, I
see some new people filled
out the workflow or the form--
so if you click Send
New Offer Letters again,
it will figure out who hasn't
had an offer letter sent
and send new offer letters
to each of these people,
and update with the yes
and the customized Google
Doc for each of them.
So I'm going to walk through the
code that makes this possible.
So there is a script editor
associated with every sheet.
And when you open up
the script editor,
you see the code
which runs it all.
And there is a bunch
of functions in here--
add menu items, send
new offer letters.
And I'll walk through
each one in turn.
So add menu items
is the first one.
And this is how the
workflows menu item got
added into your spreadsheet.
Every Google Doc-- or I'm
sorry, every app script
has this Current
Project Triggers.
You can edit triggers
with your Apps Script.
And here I'm saying when I
want to run the Add Menu items
function, when there's an event
from a spreadsheet on open--
so whenever anyone
opens the spreadsheet,
it will run this arbitrary
function that I made
and run this code.
And what this code
is saying is give me
the UI, this spreadsheet
app UI, and create a menu
in the UI, the Workflows menu.
And in that Workflows
menu, I want
to add an item whose text
is send new offer letters.
And when someone clicks
send new offer letters,
it will run this function,
send new offer letters.
And then I want to
add it to the UI.
So send new offer letters--
what does that do?
In send new offer letters, we
get the active spreadsheet.
Because this sheet is run from--
the script is run from a
spreadsheet when they clicked
the button in the UI, there's
an associated spreadsheet,
and you can get it, and then
pop up in that spreadsheet
a toast saying
sending offer letters.
Then we get the active sheet,
which is the employee tracking
sheet, and the last row,
which is the last row of data
in the spreadsheet.
We get the range of all of
the data that we care about--
the start row from the
start row and column
to the number of rows, which
is the last row minus 1,
and the number of columns
with the data we care about.
Then we get the
display values of each
of these things,
which is how they're
presented in the UI itself.
Then we iterate through
each of the bits of data
and get the data for each row--
the row number, the name, the
email, salary, manager, team,
whether or not the
offer was sent.
And if the offer
sent is not yes,
which is how I was able to
click it again and only send
new offer letters--
if they haven't said yes
that an offer was sent,
then we create an offer letter.
And I'll go through that
function in a moment.
So after we create
the offer letter,
it gives us the ID
of what document
was created for
the offer letter,
and we create this URL--
docs.google.com,
document offer ID,
and then a message that
we're going to email--
dear so-and-so, congratulations.
You're hired.
Please view your
offer letter, which
includes the next steps
at your offer URL.
Sincerely, HR.
It's a very customized message.
So then we use Mail App, which
is one of the other apps that's
built into Apps Scripts.
There's many that
exist, and Maurice is
going to go through a few more.
But Mail App is one
that you can send mail.
So you say mail app, send
email with the message.
The email is the user's email
address, the subject of You're
Hired, the message,
and just a little token
saying we don't want
people to reply to this.
And then we get the range in
the spreadsheet saying yes, we
did send an offer, and here
is the URL of your customized
offer letter.
We increment the
amount of letters
we sent, flush all of the
changes out to the spreadsheet
so it puts it in
the spreadsheet,
and then pop up a
toast saying either you
sent this many letters or
you didn't send any at all,
because there was no
new letters to send.
So how did we create
the offer letter?
So we have a
customized Google Doc,
which is the template
of the offer letter.
And in this template,
we basically
say welcome to the
next demo company.
Hello, Name.
We're thrilled to
offer you a job.
Your starting salary
will be salary.
Just basically a spreadsheet--
or I'm sorry, a doc with tokens
that we're going to
replace with customization.
So in the script, we--
using our Drive app this time,
we get the file of our ID
with the ID of our template,
and then make a copy of it.
On the copy, we then
change the sharing,
and we say this copy
can be visible to anyone
who has the link, but all
they can do is view it.
And then we change
the name of that file
to say offer letter
for so-and-so.
Then we use Document App,
which is the hook into Google
Docs within Apps Script.
And we get the doc
by Document App,
and get the body
of the document,
and then just do a
bunch of replacements.
We say for your name,
put the person's name,
for their salary, put the
person's salary, manager, team.
For the NDA, it's a
little more complex,
because we want to
do text and URL.
So we get the starting
point of where
we want to replace
text and generate a URL
and then say on this
portion within the document,
set the URL to
this NDA URL using
this other function that
I'll go through in a moment,
generate NDA URL.
And then return
the offer file's ID
so that the email that we
generated can link to it.
So how do we
generate the NDA URL?
Because if you remember,
that was served,
I mentioned, by
Apps Script hosting
as a web app in this scenario.
So generate NDA URL uses
this script app, yet
another thing that's
associated with Apps Script,
which is the script
itself as a service.
And you can get the URL of
the script app as a web app
and return this,
saying this is the URL,
and then append some parameters
to it saying here's your name,
here's your email address,
and here's your row.
And you notice I use this encode
URI component, which is just
part of JavaScript, because this
is a JavaScript environment.
So you can just call JavaScript
functions and make them work.
And there's various other
bits in generate NDA URL,
such as whether or not they're
actually signing it or just
viewing the NDA.
So how do you get Apps
Script to act as a web app?
It's pretty simple.
You publish it by clicking
this Publish button, deploy
as web app.
And then here you see do you
want to deploy it as a web app.
And it gives you the
URL and gives you
some information of the version,
who it's going to execute as,
who can access the app.
And in order to
serve it, you just
create a function called Do Get.
And Apps Script
will automatically
run this function
when someone hits
the HTTP request at that URL.
And we can get parameters from
it, such as the URL parameters.
We get the name, the email
parameter, the row parameter,
and the signed parameter.
And we just do some
basic validation here,
saying whether or not--
if the request didn't have any
of these fields, we say sorry,
we couldn't verify
your employment.
But if they did have
those fields, then
we want to hook into the
spreadsheet a bit more.
So if you remember back
at the top of the example,
we used spreadsheet app,
get active spreadsheet,
because the spreadsheet was
associated with the script
since you were running the
script from the spreadsheet.
In this scenario, you're
not running the script
from the spreadsheet,
so you can't
say get active spreadsheet.
But you can just load
an arbitrary spreadsheet
with that spreadsheet ID.
And then we say,
give me the sheet
by name of the employee
tracking sheet.
And we get the row
that the employee said
that they were at from the URL.
So in this scenario here,
we're not using great security,
because we just put an arbitrary
name, an arbitrary row.
And someone could theoretically
change their row number,
and just troll through, and
try to figure out who you're
hiring, what row they're on.
In a better example,
you could imagine
that you could generate
a random number,
put that random number in your
spreadsheet, put it in the URL,
and all of those things
have to match up.
But for demo purposes, this is
a little more straightforward
and easier to walk through.
So here we get the values
of the data in that range
and verify that the name
they gave us and the URL
matches the name in the
spreadsheet at that row.
And if it doesn't, we say sorry,
we couldn't verify things.
If they've already
signed the NDA,
then we'd just say
you've already signed it.
No more to do.
But if they haven't signed it--
and this is the request
to do the signing--
you said click here to sign
it, and they clicked it to sign
it--
then we update the spreadsheet.
We get the row, the column
that is the signing,
and say yes, you signed it.
And you can see back
in the employment
that yes, they're signed,
and some other people have
signed it.
And we spit back some
HTML saying thanks
for signing the NDA.
If this is not the signing--
if this is serving of the NDA--
then we generate a URL
for actually signing it
and create some HTML output
saying here's an NDA.
Click here to verify it.
And that's it.
It's less than 200 lines.
It's about 167 lines
and a full workflow
of how you can automate
with forms, sheets, docs,
create templates,
customize things, serve
Apps Script as a web app, and
do all of these things that
make life a lot simpler and
easier using Apps Script.
And if you can go back to
the presentation, please.
And that's it for me.
I'm going to--
Maurice is going to continue
for the rest of it for his demo.
Thank you.
MAURICE CODIK: Thanks, Sam.
Another common process we
hear a lot about is reporting.
So this is a sales
rep named Jane.
And the end of the
quarter is approaching,
and it's time for her to prep
her quarterly business review.
So she needs to load up the
data on all her accounts.
She wants to get it into Sheets.
She needs to do some analysis,
and then finally, package it
together into a nice
presentation she
can give to her team
and to her leadership.
Now, without any
kind of automation,
this would be really tedious.
She'd have to dig up the data.
She'd have to find
the presentation
she used last time.
She would have to copy paste
the data from her new data
onto the old slides.
And it's really tedious.
You can make mistakes.
You can copy paste
the wrong numbers.
And at the end of the day,
it can look really bad
if you make a mistake.
These mistakes are
not easy to catch.
So using App Script and
the G Suite REST APIs,
we can make this
process a lot easier.
We have a Google
Sheets REST API that
was designed to make it
really easy to import data
from external data sources
or third-party systems
into Google Sheets.
Last fall, we also
launched our first-ever API
for Google Slides so you
can take the data in Sheets
or another third-party system
and make a nice-looking slide
presentation with
some simple code.
So let's walk through how we
can use these REST APIs together
to make Jane's job a lot easier.
So the first step is to get the
raw data into Google Sheets.
Now, once it's there, Jane can
use the great analysis features
of Sheets, such as Explore
or all the functions that
come built in, to
understand the data,
figure out what trends
she wants to highlight,
and visualize it in
a good-looking chart,
for example.
So how do we get the data there?
Several large enterprise
partners have already
integrated with the Sheets API.
And if you use some
of these tools,
you can take advantage of that
and get the data into Sheets
very easily.
So earlier in the
conference, for example, we
announced that Salesforce
launched a new Sheets
integration where you can
import your opportunities
from Salesforce straight into
Sheets and update into Sheets,
and it will sync back and forth
between Salesforce and Sheets.
So if you're a
Salesforce user, you
can use that and get your
data into Sheets very easily.
So let's say that's
not the case.
Let's say you have some
data in internal service,
an on-premises
database, something
where you are on your own.
Thankfully, these APIs are
pretty easy to work with.
You can write a quick
program using the Sheets API,
and take that data from
your on-prem database,
and put it directly into sheets.
So let's take a look
at how this code works.
Can we switch to
the demo, please?
So here we are.
This is a Python script I wrote.
I won't go through
all of it in detail.
The bulk of it I copied from the
Google Sheets API Python Quick
Start.
And it has all of
this boilerplate
code in the beginning.
That takes care of initializing
the client libraries,
going through authentication,
and making sure
that the user gives
consent for this app
to edit their spreadsheets.
So this is boilerplate you can
get from our developer website.
I won't talk about
the bulk of that.
So here is the
core of our script.
So the first thing
we do is we have
to get the data that we
want to put into Sheets.
And here I have a
simple SQLite database
that's running on my laptop.
I have two tables,
customers, and orders,
and I'm using some SQL
to join in together
and get the data
out that I need.
So SQLite works
great for a demo,
but this could be anything.
This could be a
big data warehouse.
This could be an
on-prem Oracle database.
internal ordering service
that you need to call over HTTP.
This could really be anything.
Just plug it in with whatever
you need to get the data from.
So now let's go to the
sheet-specific parts
of the script.
So in this mean method, I
call this load data function
that gets the data
from the database.
I add a header
row to the data we
get so that it's easier for a
human to work with afterwards.
And then I start
calling the Sheets API.
So the first thing I do is I
call the spreadsheets create
method, which creates an empty
spreadsheet in Google Sheets.
Here I'm giving it the title
Imported From DB On Date
so that it's easy to pick
out from your drive later.
And then after that,
I take the data
that we got from the database
and turn it into the request
that we eventually need
to send to Sheets to get
the data there.
So I do that with the
spreadsheets value Update
Function.
And for that, I give
it the spreadsheet ID
where in the spreadsheet I
want this data to end up,
so the range A1, just
the top left beginning
of the spreadsheet.
I tell Sheets that
I want it to treat
this data as user-entered.
So it'll automatically--
it will behave as
if you typed this data by hand.
So it will understand that the
things that look like dates
are dates, the things that
look like numbers are numbers.
And again, we'll make this sheet
easier to work with at the end.
I also tell Sheets that my
data is formatted in rows.
Just because we read
this from a SQL database,
it's naturally in rows.
It's easier to import.
But if your data happens
to be shaped in columns,
you can say columns here, and
Sheets will do the right thing.
So in a pretty quick
script, I think
I have 30 lines of
actual Sheets code.
We can get data from
any data source,
practically, that the script
can talk to on Google Sheets.
So let's give that a quick run.
So it's just a Python script.
I hit Enter.
And there we are.
So it put in the URL
of the spreadsheet.
I can load here.
And I can open it up, and here's
the data from the database.
So I have the customers,
the name of each customer.
And each row is an order
that that customer placed--
so how many items
in their order,
the total dollar
amounts, and what
date the order was placed on.
So based on this,
Jane can get started.
She can do some analysis,
use some functions,
and get her work done.
Back to the slides.
So the data is in
Sheets, and Jane can
get to work doing the analysis.
So the next step is to make
this into a good-looking
presentation she
can give her team.
So for this, we'll use
the Google Slides API,
and we'll call it
from App Script
so she can work with
the spreadsheet she's
working on and with the
slides at the same time.
So using those things
together, in a few clicks,
we can get a good-looking
presentation.
So back to the demo, please.
All right.
Great.
So let's say Jane
did her analysis,
and this is what she came up.
She has a pivot table with the
top 15 customers she works with
and their sales per quarter
for the past year sorted
by their key force sales.
She also has a chart that's a
little squished on the display,
but demonstrates how
the sales per customer
has changed throughout the year,
and some other configuration
data that we need to get the
slides ready-- so what year we
care about, what
quarter, her name,
things that aren't
necessarily in the data
but end up in the
final presentation.
So there are a couple
of ways you can trigger
App Scripts from Google Sheets.
Earlier, Sam showed you that
we can add a custom menu
item where you could go
to the menu, click click,
and it will run and App
Script function for you.
Here, I created a
button, because I think
big buttons are fun to push.
So if we click Generate Slides,
now this is running my script
and taking the data
from the spreadsheet,
combining it with a
template that we created.
And in a few moments, we'll have
a nice, finished slide deck.
So here's the link to the
presentation that we created.
And this is what we end up with.
So this is a simple quarterly
business review presentation.
It has the title slide with
the quarter we're reporting on,
the year.
It has Jane's name.
We have an Executive
Summary slide that
has the chart we came up with.
It has the total revenue
for the quarter, how much we
grew compared to our goal.
We have a table describing
the top five customers
and their quarter for sales.
We have a slide with
the big, ambitious goal
to grow 12% next quarter.
And finally, we
have another slide
that has a link to
this spreadsheet
so that if you send this
presentation around,
the people looking at it
can dive into the same data
that you worked on and
either learn more about it
or double check your work.
So let's walk through the code
that powers that big button.
So there's a lot that goes into
creating a slide presentation.
So for example, here we had to--
we chose a theme.
We had to make sure the
colors are on brand.
Sometimes, you want to
use some custom logos.
So instead of writing code
to define all these things,
it tends to be a
lot easier to work
with a template presentation.
So this is the template that
we used for this example.
It has the five slides we'll
end up with at the end.
And we're using some
variables in curly braces
that we'll use some
replacements that
get the data from the sheet
and into the presentation.
So here we have a quarter
label, the year, the name.
On the executive summary,
we have the little variables
for the total sales,
the direction,
and we have a
rectangle that we'll
use to replace the
chart into that spot.
We have the table that the end
has the top five customers.
We have the slide
for a goal, and we
have a slide that we'll use
to link to the source data.
So if you notice, the variables
already have styling on them.
So instead of having to specify
all the styles by hand in code,
you can make your slides
pretty close to what they'll
end up looking like at the end.
You put the styling
on the variables,
and the Slides API
will keep that styling
when you do the replacements.
So let's look at the code
that creates the slides.
So the bulk of the work
happens in this Export
to Slides function.
This is the function
that I'm calling
when you click the big
button on the spreadsheet.
And the first thing we
do is tell the user, hey,
we're working on it.
We set some text on the ranges,
and we flush the changes
out to the spreadsheet
so that users know
that we're making progress.
The next thing we do is we grab
the data out of the spreadsheet
that we need.
Sam went through how this works.
You basically use Spreadsheet
App to pick out ranges,
and you can get the displayable
values out of those ranges.
So I'm not going to
cover that in detail
since we've already seen it.
The next step is that
we use the Drive app.
That's one of the
built-in libraries
inside of Apps Script.
And that represents
your Google Drive.
So we have the ID
of this template.
This is the ID from the URL.
And we have it coded
into our script.
So we tell Drive app get me
this file, make me a copy,
please give it this title.
So this-- we made a
copy of the template,
and then we'll use the Slides
API to modify that template
to produce the
final presentation.
So how do we talk to
Slides from Apps Script?
So here we're going to use
what's called the Slides
Advanced Service.
So an advance service
is a thin wrapped
around a Google REST API that's
available through Apps Script.
There's a pretty large list
of advanced Google services.
You can go to Resources,
Google Advanced Services.
And here's the big list of
the ones that are available.
You see I have the Slides
API, and it's turned on.
And a lot of these things are--
it's a lower-level API.
You get the full
power of the REST API.
So it ends up looking a little
different than the built-ins,
like Spreadsheet App, for
example, that was simpler.
But here you get
a lot more power.
I should mention that Slides
Advanced service launched
on Tuesday.
I actually turned it on while
I was on the flight over here
from New York.
So let's get to the
Slides-specific parts of this.
So the Slides REST API works
using a batch update model.
You basically assemble
a list of requests,
and you tell Slides please do
this, please do that, please
do that.
You send the big batch
over the Slides API,
and all those
requests get executed
in order and in atomic fashion.
So the rest of the
script basically
goes through all
the things that we
want to do to the presentation.
We assemble this big list
in Slides Requests, which
is just a JavaScript array.
And then we call the
presentations batch update
method to actually
execute those changes.
So I'll go through what the
steps are in a little detail.
So the first thing we do is that
we call over this Replace All
Text method.
So earlier, we took the
data out of the spreadsheet,
and we added it to
the data object.
And it's just a key
value of the things
we want to replace
in the template
with the data we want
to replace it with.
So the request for that
looks pretty simple.
We look at all the
keys in the data map.
We create a little object that's
the Replace All Text request.
We say Slides, please take all
of the text that matches text,
and replace it with
this replace text.
So this will go through
all of your slides
and put the data in
for all those variables
we had in the template.
The next thing we do is
that we call this Replace
Shape With Chart API.
So if you remember,
in the template,
we had a big rectangle
on the second slide
that had the text YTD Chart.
And we'll use that
as the location
of where the chart will end up.
So instead of having
to mess with--
I want the slide to be here, and
you have to nudge it a little--
sorry.
Instead of messing
with the chart
and saying I want
this chart to be here,
and fidgeting with
where to position it,
you can put a shape
in your template,
and then you can position
it where you want.
You can see it in context.
And you use Replace Shape
With Chart to actually put
the chart in that place.
So the request for
that is pretty simple.
You say I want to
replace the shape that
contains this text, which is
just a YTD chart in our case.
We tell it the spreadsheet
to grab the chart from,
which is just the
active spreadsheet
this script is being run from.
We give it the ID of the
chart, and we tell it
we want this chart to be linked.
So what I mean by
linked is that slides
will remember that this chart
came from this spreadsheet
so that if the underlying
data in Spreadsheets changes,
there will be an update button
in Slides that you can click,
and it will refresh the
chart automatically.
So that way, your data
is always up to date.
There's also an API
on the Slides API
to call refresh on
a chart for you.
So if you're working with both
the sheets API and the Slides
API, you can change
some data in Sheets
and then tell slides,
hey, there's a new chart.
Please pick it up.
So the final thing we do
is that we add a link.
From the last slide, we add
a link to the source data
so people can take a look
at the underlying data that
went into the presentation.
So the first APIs
that we worked with,
they worked in a find
and replace manner.
So we just gave them
the text in a shape,
and the API found it
and did the right thing.
Some of our other APIs--
are Object ID based.
So I have to give slides
the ID of the object that
contains the text that
we want to add a link to.
So to do that, we call
the presentations Get API
right here, and we fetch the
presentation from slides.
We pick out the final
slide, and then we
iterate through all the
elements on that slide.
So we know that slide.
We created it.
It's a title and body slide,
so it has two shapes on it--
a box for the title
and a box for the body.
And I iterate through
the two shapes on there,
and I find the one that
is the body placeholder.
So we know that's the one
that has the text that we want
to linkify, so we pass the
object ID of that shape
into this update link function.
So Update Link is
a function that
updates the textile of that
box to add a link style to it.
So we do links and
slides or textiles.
If you wanted to do
other textile changes,
like you want to make
the font different,
you want to make
it bold or italics,
you would do it in
a much similar way,
using Update Textile.
So that's all the
requests that we
needed to make the slides
look the way we want.
So we replaced all our
variables, we added the chart,
and then we added the
link to the source data.
So finally, we
call batch update,
and then we tell the user
we generated your slides.
Here's when we did it.
And we add the URL to the
presentation back to sheet.
So in all, it's probably
174 lines of code,
including the Sheets
stuff I didn't cover.
But with that, we created
a good-looking presentation
using the data in the
spreadsheet using Apps Script.
Back to the slides, please.
So using these APIs
in G Suite, Jane
saved several hours of her time.
She avoided having to do
all this manual copy paste,
and now she's ready to give
this presentation to leadership.
So that saved time.
She can get to work meeting
her next quarter goals,
or she can go outside and enjoy
the sunshine a little bit.
So we broke up the steps
here to demonstrate
what your options are.
But really, you could
automate this a lot further.
So for example, you
could have the import
to sheet script run
automatically every quarter.
You can have it--
you can say-- once
the data is there,
you can send an email to Jane
saying hey, your data is ready.
Please go take a
look and get started.
You could-- if
you wanted to, you
could skip Sheets altogether
and have your program that
queries the database do
the analysis for you,
and then go straight to
Slides, because Slides is also
REST API that you can call
from a third-party tool.
So in summary, with
some creativity
and just looking
around, I think you
can find a lot of workflows
in your enterprise
that can be automated with App
Script and the G Suite APIs,
similar to the ones
we've seen today.
And these are small automations.
These are things that you
can write in an afternoon.
You can write it in
a couple of days.
But even though they're
small, you can--
the savings add up.
If you do the same
thing for every hiring
manager, for every
party organizer,
for every sales rep
in your company,
the dollar savings just
multiply and overall can
make a big impact.
So the demos we did show you,
they do require some coding.
It's pretty simple.
Most of it is just JavaScript.
We showed some Python
code today that was also
pretty simple to write,
and those libraries
are available in pretty
much any major language.
So it does require some coding.
It's simple.
It's within the reach of power
users and IT professionals.
But it's not for everybody yet.
So if you're looking
for a low code way
to do these kind of
automations, there's
a G Suite product
called App Maker that's
currently in early access.
And that provides
a drag-and-drop UI
that lets you create apps
without really doing much code.
So if you're interested in that,
you can request access to App
Maker at
developers.google.com/appmaker.
And they also have a
showcase base at Mosconi
through the end
of the conference.
If you find them, you
can learn a lot more
about how that works.
So another good
resource for learning
about these automations is
the transformation gallery.
It's a gallery that lists
several real world use
cases of the G Suite APIs--
and not even just the APIs, but
the applications themselves--
and how you can
use them together
to transform your business.
So a lot of them come
with customer stories
so you can see what
the real business
impact was of deploying these
integrations in real life.
You can check it out
at transformationga
llery.withgoogle.com.
So wrapping up--
App Script is a lightweight
tool that lets power users
and IT professionals
write simple JavaScript
to automate actions on top
of many Google services.
So today, we showed you how to
script with Docs, with Slides,
with Sheets, with
Gmail, with Drive.
But App Scripts supports
many other Google services
that we didn't cover today.
So for example, there's
a library for Calendar,
for Translate, for
YouTube, for Maps.
And there's also that
list of advanced services
that give you more
powerful interfaces that
are easy to use to
call Google REST APIs.
So in general,
it's easy to learn.
It runs in the cloud,
and it's available to you
as part of your G
Suite subscription.
It is part of the
glue that helps
make G Suite into a true suite
of apps that work together.
So there are also REST
APIs for Sheets and Slides
that make integration with
third-party data sources easy.
So they provide simple ways
to get your data into G Suite,
where you can
collaborate on it, you
can script it using Apps Script,
you can present it to others.
So using App Script
and our Rest APIs,
you can automate
many of the tedious
process in your business,
save time and money,
and let folks focus on creating
value instead of busywork.
So to learn more about the
things we covered today,
you can check out our
developer websites
for Apps Script,
Sheets, and Slides,
and the URLs are on
the screen right now.
There's a lot of
documentation available,
and there are plenty of samples
to help you get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
as